I was getting protected back then by the
New Mexican Mafia were the most powerful
violent criminal organization in Arizona
how does a nerdy business graduate from
witness end up getting protected by the
New Mexican Mafia day one on the job my
boss slaps phonebook mail says you need
to call five hundred numbers a day to
find people to buy shares in the
beginning I wasn't any good at it but
five years in I'm the Top Gun office
grossing half a million a year got my
own staff secretary cold callers only
were twenty he's got enough money to
retire put that money into technology
shares they shot that was now became a
millionaire and I started to throw rave
parties within I started giving the
pills out for free when you give the
pills out for free you know you tracked
a lot of friends and this was just
boosting my ego but eventually my
business Studies degree took over and
greed and I started to apply that
knowledge I went out to LA picked up a
few thousand pills brought them back
sold them pretty quickly I'm getting up
to 5,000 to 10,000 from LA at a time and
my organization is getting so big now
I've got like 200 people working for me
I've got my own team of bouncers
they've all got tasers and guns and
stuff throwing parties for up to ten
thousand people so I need more pills and
the LA dealers can supply enough so I
send people out to Holland with testing
kits they brought them back we
negotiated the price down to three
dollars or less by in tens of thousands
of hits
they would put repels in just in
pillowcases in their luggage if they
wanted to be more secure they could
screw them into computer towers and then
put them on the plane this was back in
the 90s and they weren't that hip
so what axis even looked like I had one
smuggler she got stopped they took the
pill jars out of the luggage and they
said so what a day he had other vitamins
was it cool they just put them back in
the luggage
have a nice day my competitor in the
ecstasy market was Sammy the bull
Gravano on the boss of the Gambino crime
family he'd murdered almost two dozen
people and later on in prison his son
told me he'd been dispatched one night
it's a kid Natalie from a nightclub and
take me out to the desert and the only
reason they'd missed us is because my
best mate Wildman and Ida Scott fall and
we got to leave that club in a hurry so
on the drugs it was telling me you're
mr. cool guy but when I saw word up in
prison and looked back on all the
situations I put myself in I was like
how on earth he is still alive I was
getting protected back then by the New
Mexican Mafia were the most powerful and
violent criminal organization in Arizona
they were trying to hit assassinate the
head of the department of the prisons
that assassinating judges police
witnesses I was supplying pills to an
apartment party and another guy came and
he was supplying coke and weed we hit it
off and we have a conversation and then
a policeman intrudes the party he just
walks in because I could smell weed
outside nobody move and he's about to
call it in and have everybody arrested
the guy I'm speaking to the Mexican
American guy just pulls out his gun puts
it at the cops hat that says the only
one who's not leaving his you
[ __ ] everybody else go so we all
ran out into the night so I'm hiding one
of these apartments with my buddies
next thing there's like a bang bang bang
bang bang on the French window it's the
Mexican American guy it's like let me in
let me in said we let him in and at the
end of it all he said look because you
and your mates protected me me and my
brothers have got your back a month or
so later he says my brother's want to
meet you I go to this house it's got all
these lowrider show cars on the road and
then this short stocky Mexican American
guy opens the door to me so I go into
the living room all these massive
tattooed Mexican American guys prison
tats all of room wearing wife beaters
shorts down over the knees chains and
they're just looking at me like you know
who is this who is this guy kind of
thing none of them smiled at all so I'm
getting a bit nervous in this
environment and look over at the TV they
got the biggest TV I've ever seen in my
life and then on the TV I'm thinking
well it can't be I'm sure I saw that in
a Rambo movie holy [ __ ] is it was a
rocket-propelled grenade launcher and so
every time I went back to the house I
was crapping I didn't stay there very
long they never smiled ever they took
some ecstasy from me and then they
called me up and they said Shawn we've
run out of actually having a little pie
can you bring some more over over there
all of the faces on the ecstasy these
Mathew dudes and they were people they
were picking me up like they were big
sweaty teddy bears laid all the stuff I
never ever saw smile again after that
night I thought they had to catch you
with the drugs but all it takes in
Arizona is someone from seven years from
your past under the statute of
limitations to say you've sold drugs to
them and they've got a witness they
don't actually need the drugs now during
that last year when I wasn't dealing
anymore I was still going out on the
weekends getting high and they got me
talking about personal use in
did words on the phone May 16th 2002
there was a knock on my door that ended
everything so I jump up from the
computer look through the peephole and
it's blacked out go to the bedroom to my
girlfriend well like what should we do
right alright we battle and then halfway
through the living room then the door
just flies off the hinges heads get on
the ground
don't move you know you see them all up
not with those guns and you just drop
like that because you think it's based
at shooting your life is over in seconds
it's all completely gang controlled so
as soon as I go in for skinheads from
the neo-nazi Aryan Brotherhood prison
gang just come up to me and be like hey
we want a word with you get in that cell
back there and the biggest one gets in
my face he's like what are your charges
what are you charges and you a charm or
your charm well I don't know what y'all
always even watch almost child molester
so I'm just making my situation ten
times worse because I'm new to this
they've got me up against the wall now
about to smash me I show my chargesheet
they see him in for drugs nearly
everyone's imprisonment it's
drug-related and they saw my bail was
$750,000 and they thought that was cool
and then they left me alone after that
some charges RKOs by the gang which
means kill on sites such as pedophile
stuff over charges
SOS smash on site such as drive-by
shootings because women and kids
sometimes get hit any one company with a
sex offense or the crime against the
woman or a child right away gang he's
gonna try and murder them but the very
least they're gonna smash them that's
called convict justice
if someone calls you a punk [ __ ] hits
you you hit you you gotta fight him on
the spot whereas whole gang will smash
you must take showers or they'll smash
you for about hygiene care about making
friends at the guard or smashy for
snitching cargo sitting at the tables of
differences they'll smash you for that
everything you take for granted about
your safety is reverse it's be a full
member of the Aryan Brotherhood's get
patched in you've got a murder someone
for them in the jail it was half-ass
panic around was that as well and you
know you see they make the solid
teardrop one person that he's murdered
for his gang you see that teardrop
outline sorrow for the loss of fellow
gang member he murdered a rival he's
murdered your gang member you fill it in
so it's solid and not another go so they
constantly looking for people to be so
my neighbor was a serial killer my
cellmate was a Satanist he's got a
satanic inverted pentagram tattooed on
his forehead in for murder part of a
cult is drinking blood and eating human
body parts and he was actually very nice
to me the guard who put me in my new
cell decided to play a prank on me he
put me in with a guy who was a serial
home invader torturer this guy was
breaking into people's houses and taking
hammers to their kneecaps his welcoming
statement to me like I move in I've got
a padlock in a sock I could smash your
brains in well usually I could kill you
in every one rape is so common in
American prison you've got to go what's
called a rape class to get taught how
not to get raped and the class there's a
video and it shows some predators in the
dayroom
and the young people coming in and the
ones who take the sweets they're in debt
and then they can't pay it and they are
sexual favors and then they get punked
out now if you get punked out that
defines you for the rest of your stay in
prison you're basically going to be
performing oral sex and cleaning toilets
and getting rented out as a prostitute
they got a shuffle from the work crew
held him down cuts his head off with the
shovel when the head was finally after
they positioned it in a nerd the prison
where the rival gangs would see it to
make the point they were the most
violent and Rufus out of all the gangs I
take full responsibility for the harm I
caused society with drugs I thought I
was keeping the party going I saw the
horror of what the drug use led to in
the prison were 90% of the guys were
shooting on heroin and crystal meth
2/3 of hepatitis C deadly disease I knew
I couldn't change my past so I pledged
to go out and share my story and the
hope young people wouldn't make my
mistakes
[Music]
[Music]